so a t is a t is a t and thus the
japanese t must be identical to the
english t right at least this is what
we're typically taught in japanese
textbooks and japanese classrooms but
this actually isn't true um there are
two major differences between the
japanese tea and the english tea one of
which is aspiration sort of the amount
of air that we exhale when saying the t
sounds as well as the kmp sounds for
that matter aspiration however is a
little bit complicated and i've talked
about it in detail at length so i'll
just link that video down below but the
other thing is actually tongue placement
so
in the english tea if you say the word
ted the name ted for example try saying
that a few times
ted
ted ted noticing where you're where the
tip of your tongue is touching
ted
ted
so it's touching what's called the
alveolar ridge kind of that bump just
behind our upper front teeth
ted ted again if you try and say it
again with that knowledge you'll almost
certainly notice that in the japanese
tea the tip of the tongue comes in
contact with the back of the upper front
teeth
and then the blade of the tongue so kind
of the area just behind the tip of the
tongue if this is the tip of the tongue
here
then the blade of the tongue is right
here
[Music]
again so kind of just right behind the
tip of the tongue on the top but the tip
of the tongue is touching the back of
the upper front teeth and then the blade
of the tongue is touching the alveolar
ridge so in that sense the japanese tea
has just a slightly more forward tongue
position than the english tea and if i
say the word for generally in japanese
which is spelled like this
you'll almost notice immediately
if you're looking for it and this is
funny that you can actually see the
difference
that you can see more of my tongue as i
say the pet part of this word so i'll
say it a few times now
now i'm kind of exaggerating it a little
bit for the effect but again if you look
for
this more forward tongue position
in native speech you'll start to notice
it i had a conversation with a japanese
friend during study abroad and i was
trying to say that word actually which
is why i'm using it as an example and he
was saying your t sound sounds slightly
off and i said my t sounds and he said
yeah like you're saying ippon
teki teki ipanteki ipanteki but it's not
iponteki it's
and i remember not being able to hear
the difference but when he when he said
it i was like oh his tongue is more
forward in that second one i'm seeing
more of his tongue kind of in between
the sides of his uh well on the sides of
his upper front teeth and again this is
because the tongue placement is
different so just to summarize things in
the japanese tea the tip of the tongue
is touching the back of the upper front
teeth and the blade of the tongue is
touching the alveolar ridge this is
different from the english tea in which
only the tip of the tongue is touching
the alveolar ridge at least in american
english i hope that this was useful i
teach japanese pronunciation on patreon
linked below if anyone's interested in
that good luck with your japanese
studies and talk to all you guys again
soon